Despite the fact that Camera360 has been around for 8 years
the passion to create better photographic experience using new technologies
has always been strong since day one
Hello everyone, I’m Hao Xu
founder & CEO of Camera360
The passion towards photography actually came from my father
Since he is a photographer himself
he gave me some of my earliest encounters and influence on photography
After growing up
I also wanted more people to experience the beauty of photography
Using technology and innovation
to bring powerful, flexible shooting experiences to the audience
Up to this day, mobile devices have become more and more diverse
in order to satisfy users
and to inspire their creative appetite
a more open platform and more advanced technologies are a necessity
Hello, I’m Tao Li, technical lead of Camera360
We began paying attention to Kotlin programming language years ago
As soon as it became an official language for Android development
we decided to popularize Kotlin use within our company
Ever since dipping our toes into Kotlin through StudyJams
to company-wide study sessions that happen twice a week
our engineers showed lots of passion towards the language
It has to do with the fact that Kotlin has a relatively reasonable learning curve
and many highly efficient syntactic features
A great deal of syntactic sugar, with different modern programming language features
like native lambda expression
makes Kotlin a great tool to dramatically boost our development efficiency
For example, the brand new modules we developed using Kotlin
only took three months to be production-ready
Refactoring existing code with Kotlin also proved to be quite beneficial
What used to be 200 lines of Java code
became 86 lines after using Kotlin
As for stability, we compared a project mostly written in Java language
with another primarily consists of Kotlin code
we found the latter demonstrates reduced NullPointerExceptions notably
I'm Rui Gu, co-founder & COO of Camera360
Using new technologies to improve and polish user experience is also essential
We used Android vitals to decrease excessive wakeups
from 4.51% to 0.01%
crash rate decreased from 0.99% to 0.27%
This resulted in our monthly rating increase from 4.341 to 4.471
After releasing the innovative animated sticker feature
we became the most popular camera app in Japan
Now we are more than confident to use new technology in our product
such as Google ARCore, to further enhance our use experience
and achieve better photographic results
Actively utilizing new technology asap
as well as investment in independent R&D
made it possible for Camera360 to stay well received over a long period of time in the global market
We believe we would be able to
reach more and more global audience on Google Play
and create more smiles and happiness in return by bringing our products to them